so we're now starting um in week three
with um lecture five
so
unfortunately on the last class i i
guess i really got behind and went a bit
slowly i guess i must just enjoy talking
about natural languages too much and so
i never really got to the punch line of
showing how you could do good things
with the neural dependency parser so
today for the first piece i'll in some
sense be finishing the content of last
time and talk about neural dependency
parsing which also gives us the
opportunity um to introduce a simple
feed forward neural net classifier um
that will then lead into a little bit of
just background things that you need to
know about neural networks content
because the fact of the matter is there
is a bunch of stuff you need to know
about neural networks and then after
both of those things i'll get into
what's really meant to be the topic of
today's lecture which is looking at
language modeling and recurrent neural
networks and that's then going to lead
into
those two things are important topics
that we'll then be talking about really
for the whole of next week as well
there's a couple of reminders before we
get underway the first is
that you should have handed in
assignment 2 before you
joined this class and in turn assignment
three is out today and it's an
assignment um where you're going to
build essentially the new
um dependency parser that i'm just about
to present in pytorch so part of the
role of this assignment is actually to
get you up to speed with pytorch so this
assignment is highly scaffolded with
lots of comments and hints about what to
do and so the hope is that
by the time you come to the end of it
you'll feel fairly familiar and
comfortable with pie torch don't forget
there was also tutorial on pie torch
last week if you didn't catch that at
the time you might want to go back and
look at the video
another thing to mention about the
assignments is that assignment three is
the last assignment where our great team
of tas are happy to look at your code
and sort out your bugs for you
so maybe take advantage of that but not
too much
but starting an assignment four for
assignments four five and the final
project um the tas are very happy to
help in general but it's just not going
to be their job to be actually sorting
out bugs for you
you should be looking at your code and
discussing ideas and concepts and
reasons why things might not work with
them
okay so if you remember where we were
last time
i'd introduced this idea of transition
based dependency parsers and that these
were an efficient linear time method um
for giving the syntactic structure of
natural language text
and
that they worked pretty well before
neural nets came along and took over nlp
again but they had some disadvantages
and their biggest disadvantage is that
like most machine learning models of
that time they worked with indicator
features so that means that you are
specifying some condition and then
checking whether it was true of a
configuration so something like the word
on the top of the stack is good and it's
part of speech is adjective
or the next word coming up is a
personal pronoun that those are
conditions that would be features and
a conventional um
transition based dependency parser and
so what are the problems with doing that
well one problem is that those features
are very sparse
a second problem is the features are
incomplete well what i mean by that is
depending
on
what
words and configurations occurred in the
training data there are certain features
that will exist because you sort of saw
a certain word preceding a verb and
certain features that just won't exist
because that word never occurred before
a verb in the training data
but perhaps the biggest problem and
opportunity
for doing better with the neural
dependency parser is that it turns out
that in a symbolic dependency parser
computing all these features just turns
out to actually be pretty expensive that
although the actual transition system
that i showed last time is fast and
efficient to run you actually have to
compute all of these features and what
you found was that about 95 of the
parsing time of one of these models was
spent just computing all of the features
of every
configuration so that suggests that
perhaps we can do better with a neural
approach where we're going to learn a
dense and compact feature representation
and so that's what i want to go through
now
so this time we're still going to have
exactly the same kind of configuration
of a stack and a buffer and running
exactly the same
transition sequence except this time
rather than representing the
configuration the stack and the buffer
by having several million symbolic
features we're instead going to
summarize this configuration as a dense
vector of dimensionality perhaps
approximately a thousand
and our neural approach is going to
learn this dense compact feature
representation
and so quite explicitly what i'm going
to
show you now briefly and what you're
going to implement
is essentially the neural dependency
parser that was developed by dante chen
in 2014
and to
skip to the advertisement right at the
beginning as to how this works so well
these are the kind of results that you
got from it using the measures that i
introduced at the last time the
unlabeled attachment score whether you
attach dependencies correctly um to the
right word and the labeled attachment
score as to whether you also get the
type of grammatical relation of that
dependency correct
um and so essentially um this chin and
manning parser gave a neural version of
something like a transition based
dependency parser like malt parser in
yellow
and the interesting thing was that
taking advantage of a neural classifier
in ways that i'm about
to
explain that that could produce
something that was about two percent
more accurate than the symbolic
dependency parser and because of the
fact that it's not doing all the
symbolic feature computation despite the
fact that you might think at first that
there's a lot of real number math and
matrix vector multiplies in a neural
dependency parser it actually ran
noticeably faster than the symbolic
dependency parser because it didn't have
um all the feature compute
computation the other major approach to
dependency parsing that i'm also showing
here and i'll get back to at the end is
what's referred to as graph based
dependency parsing and so that's a
different approach to dependency parsing
and so these are two symbolic
graph-based dependency parsers and
in the pre-neural world they were
somewhat more accurate
than the transition based parses as you
could see
but on the other hand they were close to
two orders of magnitude slower um and so
essentially with the chern manning
parser we were able to provide something
that was basically as accurate as the
best graph based dependency parsers
which were the best dependency parsers
while operating about two orders of
magnitude more quickly
so how did we do it it was actually a
very straightforward
implementation which is part of what
makes it great
for doing for assignment three
um but this is how we did it and we got
wins so the first win which is what
we've already talked about extensively
starting in week one is to make use of
distributed representations so we
represent each word as a word embedding
and you've had a lot of experience with
that already and so that means
when words weren't seen in a particular
configuration we still know what they're
like because they'll be we'll have seen
similar words in the correct
configuration
um but we don't stop only with word
embeddings
the other things that are central to our
dependency parser are the parts of
speech of words and the dependency
labels and so what we decided to do is
that although those are much smaller
sets
so the dependency labels are about 40 in
number and the parts of speech are of
around that order of magnitude sometimes
less sometimes more that even within
those sets of categories there are ones
that are very strongly related so we
also adopted um distributed
representations for them so for example
there might be parts of speech for
singular nouns and plural nouns and
basically most of the time they behave
similarly and there are adjectival
modifiers and numerical modifiers so
these are just numbers like three four
five and again a lot of the time they
behave the same that you have both
three cows and brown cows
okay so everything is going to be
represented in a distributed
representation so at that point we have
exactly the same kind of configuration
where we have our stack our buffer and
we've started to build some arcs and so
the
classification decisions of the next
transition are going to be made out of a
few elements of this configuration so
we're looking at the top thing on the
stack um the thing second on the stack
the first word on the buffer and then we
actually added in some additional
features that are then to the extent
that we've already built arcs for words
on the stack that we can be looking at
the dependence on the left and right of
those words that are on the stack that
are already in the sets of arcs
and so for each of those things they
there is a word
there is a part of speech
and for some of them there is a
dependency um where it's already
connected up to something else so for
example the left corner of s2 here has
an n sub dependency back to the second
thing on the stack
so we can take these elements of the
configuration and can
look up the embedding of each one so we
have word embeddings part of speech
embeddings and dependency embeddings and
just concatenate them all together kind
of like we did before with the window
classifier and that will give us a newer
representation of the configuration
now there's a second reason why we can
hope to win
by using a deep learning classifier to
predict the next transition and we
haven't really said much about that yet
so i just wanted to
detour and say a little bit more about
that um so the simplest kind of
classifier that's close to what
we've been talking about in neural
models is a soft max classifier so that
if we have d dimensional vectors x
and we have y classes to assign things
to
um
oh sorry y is an element of a set of um
c classes to assign things to
then we can build a softmax classifier
using the softmax distribution that
we've seen before where we decide the
classes based on having a weight matrix
that's
c by d
and we train on supervised data the
values of this w weight matrix to
minimize our negative log
likelihood loss that we've seen before
um a loss is also commonly referred to
as cross-entropy loss a term that you'll
see in pie torch among other places
um so that is a straightforward machine
learning classifier and if you've done
229 and you've seen soft max classifiers
um but a simple softmax classifier like
this
um shares with most traditional machine
learning classifiers so models include
naive bayes models support vector
machines logistic regression
that at the end of the day they're not
very powerful classifiers they're
classifiers that only give linear
decision boundaries and so this can be
quite limiting so if you have a
difficult problem like the one i'm
indicating
in the picture in the bottom left well
there's just no way you can divide the
green points from the red points by
simply drawing a straight line so you're
going to have a quite imperfect
classifier
so the second big win of neural
classifiers is that they can be much
more powerful because they can provide
non-linear classification
so rather than only being able to do
something like in the left picture um we
can come up with classifiers that do
something like in the right picture and
therefore can separate the green and the
red points um as an aside um these
pictures i've taken from andre caparti's
compnet js software which is a kind of a
fun little tool to play around with if
you've got a bit of spare time
um and so there's something subtle going
on here is because our more powerful
neural net classifiers at the end of the
day what they have at the top of them is
a softmax
layer and so this softmax layer is
indeed a linear classifier and it's
still a linear classifier but what they
have below that is other layers of
neural net and so effectively what
happens is that the classification
decisions are linear as far as the top
softmax is concerned but non-linear in
the original representation space so
precisely what a neural net can do is
warp
the space around and move the
representation of data points to provide
something that at the end of the day can
be classified by a linear classifier
and so that's what a simple feedforward
neural network multi-class classifier
does so it starts with an input
representation so these are is some
dense representation of the input
it puts it through a hidden layer h with
a
matrix multiply followed by
non-linearity so that matrix multiply
can transform the space and map things
around and so then the output of that we
can then put into a soft max layer and
get out soft max probabilities from
which we make our classification
decisions
and
to the extent that our probabilities
don't assign one to the correct class we
then get some log loss or cross entropy
error which we back propagate towards
the parameters and embeddings of our
model
and as the learning that goes on via
back propagation we increasingly well
learn parameters of this hidden layer of
the model which learn to re-represent
the input they move the inputs around in
an intermediate hidden vector space so
it can be easily classified with what at
the end of the day is the linear softmax
so this is basically the whole of a
simple feed for neural network
multi-class classifier but um and if we
had something like a a visual signal we
just sort of feed straight in here
real numbers and we've been done but
normally with um human language material
we actually effectively have one more
layer that we're feeding in before that
because really below this dense input
layer we actually have one hot vectors
for what words or parts of speech were
involved and then we're doing a lookup
process which you can think of as one
more matrix multiply to convert the one
hot features into our dense input layer
okay in my picture here the one other
thing that's different is i've
introduced a different non-linearity in
the hidden layer which is a rectified
linear unit
and that's what we'll be using now
neural dependency parsers um it looks
like the picture in the bottom right and
i'll come back um to that in a few
minutes that's one of the extra neural
net things um to talk about
okay so our neural net dependency parser
model architecture is essentially
exactly that um but applied to the
configuration of our transition based
dependency parser so based on our
transition based dependency parser
configuration we construct an input
layer embedding by looking up on the
various elements as i discussed
previously and then we feed it through
this
hidden layer to the softmax layer
to get probabilities out of which we can
choose what the next action is
and it's no more complicated than
that um but what we found is um that
just
simply you
you know in some sense using the
simplest kind of feed forward
neural um classifier could provide
a
very accurate
dependency parser
that determines the structure of
sentences supporting meaning
interpretation the kind of way that i
suggested last time
indeed you know despite the fact
that it was a quite simple architecture
in 2014 this was the first successful
neural dependency parser and the dense
representations especially
but also partly the non-linearity of the
classifier
gave us this good result that it could
both outperform
symbolic parsers in terms of accuracy
and it could outperform them in terms of
speed
um so that was 2014
just quickly here a couple more slides
on
what's happened since then
so lots of people got excited by the
success of this new dependency parser
and a number of people particularly at
google then cetera about building a
bigger fancier
transition based neural dependency
parser so they explored bigger deeper
networks there's no reason to only have
one hidden layer
you can have two hidden layers um you
can do beam search that i briefly
mentioned last time
another thing that i'm not going to talk
about now is adding
conditional random field
style inference over decision sequences
and that then led in 2016 um for a model
that they called um parsi mcpa's face
which is hard to say with a straight
face um which was then about
two and a half three percent um more
accurate than the model that we had
produced but still in basically the same
family of transition based parser with
the neural net classifier to choose the
next transition
um
the alternative to transition based
parsers as graph based dependency
parsers and for a graph-based dependency
parser
what you're doing is effectively
considering every pair of words and
considering a word as a dependent of
root and you're coming up with a score
as to how likely is it
that big is a dependent of root or how
likely is big to be
dependent of cat and similarly for every
other word for the word sat um how
likely
is it to be a dependent of root or a
dependent of the etc
and well to do that well you need to
know more than just what the two um
words involved are and so what you want
to do is understand the context so you
want to have an understanding of the
context of big what's to the left of
what's to the right of it to understand
how you might hook it up into the
dependency representations of the
sentence
um
and so while they've been previous work
in graph based dependency parsing like
the mst parser i showed on the earlier
results slide
it seemed appealing
that we could come up with a much better
representation of context using neural
nets that look at context and how we do
that is actually what i'll be talking
about in the end part of the lecture and
so at stanford um we became interested
in trying to work out how to come up
with a better graph-based dependency
parser using context sorry i forgot this
this was showing that um if we can score
each pairwise dependency we can simply
choose the best one so we can say um
probably big is a dependent of cat and
to a first approximation we're going to
want to choose for each word
that it is a dependent of the word that
seems most likely to be a dependent but
we want to do that with some constraints
because we want to get out something
that is a tree with a single root as i
discussed last time and you can do that
by making use of a minimum spanning tree
algorithm that uses these scores of how
likely different dependencies are
okay so then in 2017
another student tim doset and me then
worked on um saying well can we now also
build a much better
neural graph-based dependency parser and
we developed a novel
method for scoring um
neural
scoring dependency parses and a graph
based model which i'm not going to get
into the details of right now but that
also had a very nice result because use
getting back to graph based parsing we
could then build a graph based parser
that performed about a percent better
than the best of the the google
transition based new dependency parsers
but i should point out that this is a
mixed win because although its accuracy
is better
these graph-based parsers are just in
squared in performance rather than
linear time so kind of like the early
results i showed
they don't operate nearly as quickly
when you're wanting to
pass large amounts of text with complex
long sentences
okay so that's everything you need to
know about dependency parsers and to do
assignment three so grab it this evening
and start to work um but i did want to
sort of before going on to the next
topic just mention a few more things um
about neural networks since um some of
you know this well already some of you
have seen less of it but you know there
just are a bunch of things you have to
be aware of um for building new networks
now again for assignment three
essentially we give you everything and
if you follow the recipe your parser
should work well
but you know
what you should minimally do is actually
you know look carefully at some of the
things
that this parser does which is questions
like how do we initialize our
matrices of our neural network
what kind of optimizers do we use and
things like that um
because these are all important
decisions and so i wanted to say just a
few words about that
okay so the first thing that we haven't
discussed at all is the concept of
regularization
so when we're building these neural nets
we're now building models with a huge
number of parameters
so
essentially
just about all neural net models that
work well
actually
they're full loss function is a
regularized loss function so for this um
loss function here of j well this part
here is the part that we've seen before
um where we're using a soft max
classifier and then taking a negative
log likelihood loss which we're then
averaging over the different examples
but actually we then stick on the end of
it
this regularization term and so this
regularization term
sums the square of every parameter in
the model
and so what that effectively says is
you only want to make
parameters
non-zero if they're really useful
right so the to the extent the
parameters don't help much you're just
being penalized here um by making them
non-zero but to the extent that the
parameters do help you'll gain in your
estimation of likelihood and therefore
it's okay for them to be non-zero in
particular um notice that this penalty
is assessed only once per parameter it's
not being assessed separately for each
example
okay and having this kind of
regularization um is essential to build
neural net models that regularize well
so the classic problem is referred to as
overfitting and what overfitting means
is that if you have a particular
training data set and you start training
your model
your error will go down because you'll
shift the parameters so they better
predict um the
the correct answer
for data points in the model and you can
keep on doing that and it will start
keep on reducing your error rate but if
you then look at your partially trained
classifier and say how well does this
classifier classify
independent data different
test data that you weren't training the
model on what you'll find is up until a
certain point um
you'll get better at classifying
independent test examples as well and
after that
commonly what will happen is you'll
actually start to get worse at
classifying independent test examples
even though you're continuing to get
better at predicting the training
examples and so this was then referred
to as you're over fitting
the training examples that you're
fiddling the parameters of the model so
they're really good at predicting the
training examples which aren't useful
things
that can then predict um on independent
examples that you come to at runtime
okay um
that classic view of regularization
is sort of actually
outmoded and wrong for modern neural
networks um
so
the right way to think of it for the
kind of modern big neural networks that
we build is that
overfitting on the training data isn't a
problem but nevertheless you need
regularization
to make sure that your models generalize
well to independent test data so what
you'd like is for your graph not to look
like this
example with test error starting to head
up you'd like to have it
at worst case
flat line and best case still be
gradually dropping it'll always be
higher than the training error but it's
not actually showing a failure to
generalize
so when we train
big neural nets these days
our
big neural nets
always overfit on the training data they
hugely overfit on the training data in
fact in many circumstances our neural
nets have so many parameters that you
can continue to train them on the
training data until the error on the
training data is zero they get every
single example right because they can
just memorize enough stuff about it to
predict the right answer but in general
providing the models are regularized
well those models will still also
generalize well and predict well on
independent data
and so for part of what we want to do
for that is to work out how much to
regularize and so this lambda parameter
here is the strength of regularization
so if you're making that lambda number
big
you're getting more regularization and
if you're making it smaller you're
getting less and you don't want to have
it be too big or else you won't fit the
data well and you don't want to be too
small
or else
you have the problem that you don't
generalize well
okay so this is classic l2
regularization and it's a starting point
but our big neural nets are sufficiently
complex and have sufficiently many
parameters that essentially l2
regularization doesn't cut it so the
next thing that you should know about
and is a very standard good feature
for building neural nets is a technique
called drop out
so dropout
is generally introduced as a sort of a
slightly funny process that you do when
training
to avoid feature coat
co-adaptation so in dropout what you do
is at the time that you're training your
model
that for each
instance or for each batch
in your training
then for each neuron in the model
you drop 50 of its inputs you just treat
them as zero
and so that you can do by sort of
zeroing out elements of um the sort of
layers
um
and
then at test time you don't drop any of
the model weights you keep them all but
actually you have all the model weights
because you're now keeping twice as many
things as you'd use the training data
um
and so effectively that little recipe
um prevents what's called feature
co-adaptation
so
um
you can't
you can't have features um that are only
useful in the presence of particular
other features because the model can't
guarantee
which features are going to be present
for different examples because different
features are being randomly dropped all
of the time and so effectively
dropout gives you a kind of a middle
ground between naive bayes and the
logistic regression model and the naive
bayes models all the weights are said
independently in a logistic regression
model all the weights are set in the
context of all the others and here you
are aware of other weights but they can
randomly disappear from you it's also
related to ensemble models like model
bagging because you're using different
subsets of the features every time
um
but
after all of those explanations there's
actually another way of thinking about
dropout which was actually developed
here at stanford this paper by percy
liang and students um which is to argue
that really what dropout gives you is a
strong regularizer that isn't a uniform
regularizer like l2 that regularizes
everything with an l2 last but can learn
a feature dependent regularization and
so that dropout has just emerged as in
general the best way
to do regularization for neural nets
i think you've already seen and heard
this one but just
have it on my slides once
if you want to have your neural networks
go fast
it's really essential that you make use
of vectors matrices tensors and you
don't do things with for loops so here's
a tiny example
where i'm
using time it
which is a useful thing that you can use
too to see what how fast your neural
nets run and different ways of writing
that
and so when i'm doing this um
doing these
dot products here i can either
do it the dot product in a for loop
against each word vector or i can do the
dot product with with a single word
vector matrix and if i do it in a for
loop
doing each
loop takes me
almost a second
whereas if i do it with a
matrix multiply it takes me an order of
magnitude less time so you should always
be looking to use vectors and matrices
not for loops and this is a speed up of
about 10 times when you're doing things
on a cpu
heading forward we're going to be using
gpus and they only further exaggerate
the advantages of using vectors and
matrices where you'll commonly get two
orders of magnitude speed up um by doing
things that way
yeah so for the backward pass
you are
running a backward passes before on the
dropped out
examples right so
for the things that were dropped out no
gradient is going through them because
they weren't present they're not
affecting things
so in a particular
batch
you're only
training weights for the things that
aren't dropped out but then since you
for each successive um batch you drop
out different things that over a bunch
of batches you're then training all of
the weights of the model
um and so feature dependent regularizer
is
meaning
that
how much a feature the different
features can be
regularized different amounts
to
maximize performance so back in this
model
every
feature was
just so being penalized by taking lambda
times at squared values so this is sort
of uniform regularization
where the end result of this
dropout style training is that you end
up with some features
being regularized much more strongly and
some other features
being regularized less strongly and how
much
they be regularized depends on how much
they're being used so you're
regularizing more features that are
being used less but i'm
i'm not going to get through into the
details of how you can understand that
perspective um that's the that's um
outside of the context of what i'm going
to get through right now
so the final bit is i just wanted to
give a little bit of perspective on
non-linearities in our neural nets
so
the first thing to remember is you have
to have non-linearity so if you're
building a multi-layer neural net and
you've just got you know w1 x plus b1
then you put it through w to
x plus b2 and then put through w3 um
x
well i guess they're different hidden
layers so i should have said x they
should be hidden one hidden two hidden
three w3 hidden three plus b3 um that
multiple linear transformations
um compose so they can be just collapsed
down into a single linear transformation
so you don't get any power as
a data representation
by having multiple linear layers there's
a slightly longer story there because
you actually do get some interesting
learning effects but i'm not going to
talk about that now
but standardly we have to have some kind
of
non-linearity to do something
interesting in a deep neural network
okay so this there's a starting starting
point as the most classic non-linearity
is the logistic often just called the
sigmoid um non-linearity because of its
s shape um which we've seen before in
previous lectures so this will take any
real number and map it on the to the
range of zero one um
and that was sort of basically what
people used in sort of 1980s neural nets
now one disadvantage of this
non-linearity
um
is that it's moving everything into the
positive space because the output is
always between zero and one so people
then decided that for many purposes it
was useful to have this variant sigmoid
shape of
hyperbolic tan which is then being shown
in the second picture
now you know logistic and hyperbolic tan
um they sound like they're very
different things but actually as you
maybe remember from a math class
hyperbolic tan can be represented in
terms of exponentials as well and if you
do a bit of math which possibly we might
make you do on an assignment um it's
actually the case that a hyperlog
tangent is just a rescaled and shifted
version of the logistics so it's really
exactly the same curve just squeezed a
bit so it goes now symmetrically between
minus one and one
um
well
these kind of transcendental functions
like hyperbolic tangent they're kind of
slow and expensive to compute right even
on our fast computers calculating
exponentials is a bit slow so something
people became interested in was well
could we do things with much simpler
non-linearity so what if we used
a so-called hard tan h so the hard 10h
at
some point up to some point it just flat
lines at -1
then it is
y equals x
up until one and then it just flat lines
again
and you know that seems a slightly weird
thing to use because if your input is
over on the
left or over on the right
you're sort of not getting any
discrimination in it for things giving
the same output
but somewhat surprisingly i mean i was
surprised when people um started doing
this um
these kind of models um proved to be
very successful and so that then led
into
what's proven to be kind of the most
successful and generally widely used
non-linearity and a lot of recent deep
learning work which was what was being
used um in the
dependency powers model i showed is
what's called the rectified linear unit
or value so a value is kind of the
simplest kind of non-linearity that you
can imagine so if the value of x is
negative its value is zero so
effectively it's just dead it's not
doing anything in the computation and if
its value of x is greater than zero then
it's just simply y equals x the value is
being passed through
um
and at first sight this might seem
really really weird and how could this
be useful as a non-linearity but if you
sort of think a bit about how you can
approximate things
with piecewise linear functions very
accurately you might kind of start to
see how you could use this to do
accurate
function approximation with piecewise
linear functions and that's what value
units have been found to do extremely
extremely successfully um so logistic
and tan h are still used in various
places you use logistic when you on a
probability output we'll see 10 h's
again very soon when we get to recurrent
neural networks um but they're no longer
the default when making deep networks
that in a lot of places the first thing
you should think about trying is relu
non-linearities and so in particular um
that
why part of why they're good is that
religion on
networks train very quickly because you
get this sort of very straightforward
gradient backflow because providing you
on the right hand side of it you then
just getting this sort of constant
gradient backflow from the slope one and
so they train very quickly
the somewhat surprising fact is that
sort of almost the simplest
non-linearity imaginable is still enough
to have a very good neural network but
it just is um people have played around
with variants of that um so people have
then played around with leaky rail use
where rather than
the left hand side just going completely
to zero it goes slightly negative on a
but much
shallower slope and then there's been a
parametric reload where you have an
extra parameter where you learn the
slope of the negative part um
another thing that's been used um
recently is this swish non-linearity
which looks almost like a value um but
it sort of curves down just a little bit
there and starts to go up i mean i think
it's fair to say that you know none of
these have really proven themselves
vastly superior there are papers saying
i can get better results by using one of
these and maybe you can
but you know it's not night and day and
the vast majority of work that you see
around is still just using values in
many places
okay
a couple more things
parameter initialization
so
in almost all cases you must must must
initialize um the matrices of your
neural nets with small random values
neural nets just don't work if you start
the matrices off as zero because
effectively then everything is symmetry
is symmetric
nothing can specialize in different ways
and
and you then get sort of
uh
you just don't have an ability for a
neural net to learn you sort of get this
defective solution
so
standardly you're using some method such
as
drawing random numbers uniformly between
minus r and r for a small value r and
just filling in all the parameters with
that the exception is with bias weights
it's fine to set bias weights to zero
and in some sense that's better
in terms of choosing what the r value is
essentially for traditional neural nets
what we want to set that our range for
is so that the numbers in our neural
network stay of a reasonable size they
don't get too big and they don't get too
small and
whether they kind of blow up or not
depends on how many connections there
are in the neural network so looking at
the fan in and fan out of
connections in the neural network and so
a very common
initialization that you'll see in pi
torch is what's called javier
initialization named after a person
who suggested that
and it's working out a value of uh based
on
um
this fan in and fan out of the layers
but you can just sort of ask for it say
initialize with this initialization and
it will
this is another area where there have
been some subsequent
developments so around
week five we'll start talking about
layer normalization if you're using
layer normalization then it sort of
doesn't matter the same how you
initialize the weights
so finally
we have to train our models and i've
briefly introduced the idea of
stochastic gradient descent and you know
the good news is that most of the time
that if training your networks with
stochastic gradient descent works just
fine
use it and you will get good results
however
often that requires
choosing a suitable learning rate which
is my final
slide of tips on the next slide but
there's been an enormous amount of work
on optimization of neural networks and
people have come up with a whole series
of more sophisticated optimizers
and i'm not going to get into the
details of optimization in this class
but the very loose idea is that these
optimizers are adaptive in that they can
kind of keep track of how much slope
there was how much gradient there is for
different parameters and therefore based
on that make decisions as to how much to
adjust the weights
when doing the gradient update rather
than adjusting it by a constant amount
and so in that family of methods
there are methods that include edegrad
rms prop adam and then a variants of
adam including sparse adam adam w etc
the the one called atom is a pretty good
place to start um and a lot of the time
that's a good one to use and again from
the perspective of pie torch when you're
initializing an optimizer you can just
say please use adam and you don't
actually need to know much more about it
than that
if you are
um
using simple stochastic gradient send
you have to change choose a learning
rate so that was the eta value that you
multiplied
the gradient by for how much to adjust
the weights and so i talked about that
slightly how you didn't want it to be
too big or your model could diverge or
bounce around you didn't want it to be
too small or else training could um take
place exceedingly slowly and you'll miss
the assignment deadline um you know how
big it should be depends on all sorts of
details of the model and so you sort of
want to try out some different
order of magnitude numbers to see what
numbers seem to work well for it
training stability but reasonably
quickly something around 10 to the minus
3 or 10 to the minus 4 isn't a crazy
place to start
in principle you can do fine just using
a constant learning rate in sgd in
practice people generally find they can
get better results by decreasing
learning rates as you train so a very
common recipe is that you halve the
learning rate after every k epochs where
an epoch means that you've made a pass
through the entire set of training data
so perhaps something like every three
epochs you have the learning rate
and a final little note there in purple
is when you make a pass through the data
you don't want to go through the data
items in the same order each time
because that leads you just kind of be
have a sort of patterning of the
training examples that the model will
sort of fall into that periodicity of
those patterns so it's best to shuffle
the data before each pass through it
okay there are more sophisticated ways
to set learning rates um and i won't
really get into those now
fancier optimizers like adam also have a
learning rate so you still have to
choose a learning rate value but it's
effectively it's an initial learning
rate which typically the optimizer
shrinks as it runs and so um you
commonly want to have the number it
starts off with beyond the larger size
because it will be shrinking as it as it
goes
okay so that's all by way of
introduction and i'm now ready to start
on language models and rnns so what is
language modeling i mean as two words of
english language modeling could mean
just about anything but in the natural
language processing literature language
modeling has a very precise technical
definition which you should know
so language modeling is the task of
predicting the word that comes next
um so if you have some context like the
students open there
you want to be able to predict what
words will come next is it their books
their laptops their exams their minds
and so in particular
what you want to be
doing is being able to give a
probability that different words will
occur in this context so a language
model is a probability distribution over
next words given a preceding context
and a system that does that is called a
language model
so
as a result of that you can also think
of a language model as a system that
assigns a probability score to a piece
of text so if we have a piece of text
then we can just work out its
probability according to a language
model so the probability of a sequence
of tokens we can decompose via the chain
rule probability of the first times
probability the second given the first
etc etc and then we can work that out
using what our language model provides
as a product of each probability of
predicting the next word
okay language models are really the
cornerstone of human language technology
everything that you do
with computers that involves human
language you are using language models
so when you're using your phone and it's
suggesting whether well or badly what
the next word that you probably want to
type is and that's a language model
working to try and predict likely next
words
when the same thing happens in a google
doc and it's suggesting a next word or a
next few words that's a language model
you know the main reason why the one
in google docs works much better than
the one on your phone is that for the
keyboard phone models they have to be
very compact um so they can run quickly
and not much memory
so they're sort of only mediocre
language models where something like
google docs can do a much better
language modeling job
query completion same thing there's a
language model
and so then the question is well how do
we um build language models and so i
briefly wanted to first again um give
the traditional answer um since you
should have at least some understanding
of how
nlp was done without a neural network
and the traditional answer that powered
speech recognition and other
applications for at least two decades
three decades really
was what were called engram language
models and these were very simple but
still quite effective idea so we want to
give probabilities of next words
so
what we're going to work with is what
are referred to as n grams and so n
grams is just a chunk of n consecutive
words
which are usually referred to as
unigrams bigrams trigrams and then four
grams and five grams
a horrible set of names which would
offend any humanist
but that's what people normally say
and so effectively what we do is just
collect statistics about how often
different engrams
occur in a large amount of text and then
use those to build a probability model
so the first thing we do is what's
referred to as making a markov
assumption so these are also referred to
as markov models and we decide that the
word and position t plus one only
depends on the preceding n minus one
words
so
if we want to predict t plus one given
the entire
preceding text we actually throw away
the early words and just use the
preceding n minus one words as context
well once we made that simplification we
can then just use the definition of
conditional probability and say all that
conditional probability is the
probability of n words
divided by
the preceding n minus one words and so
we have the probability of an n gram
over the probability of an n minus one
gram
and so then how do we get these n gram
and n minus one gram probabilities we
simply take a large amount of text in
some language and we count how often the
different engrams occur
and so our crude statistical
approximation starts off as the count of
the engram over the count of the n minus
one gram
so here's an example of that suppose
we're learning a foreground language
model okay so we throw away all words
apart from the last three words and
they're our conditioning
we look um
in some
large we use the counts from some large
training corpus and we see how often did
students open their books occur how
often did students open their minds
occur
and then for each of those counts
we divide through by the count of how
often students open their occurred and
that gives us our probability estimates
um
so for example if in the corpus students
open there occurred a thousand times
students open their books occurred 400
times
we'd get a probability estimate of 0.4
for books if exams occurred 100 times
you get 0.1 for exams
and we sort of see here already the
disadvantage of having made the markov
assumption and have gotten rid of all of
this earlier context
which would have been useful for helping
us to predict
um
the one other point um that i'll just
mention that i confuse myself on is
this count of the engram language model
so for a foreground language model it's
called a foreground language model
because in its estimation you're using
four grams in the numerator and
trigrams in the denominator so you use
the the size of the numerator so that
terminology is different to the
terminology that's used in markov models
so when people talk about the order of a
markov model that refers to the amount
of context you're using so this would
correspond to a third order markup model
um
yeah so someone said is this similar to
a naive bayes model
sort of
naive bayes models you also estimate the
probabilities just by counting um so
they're
they're related
and they're sort of in some sense two
differences
um
the first difference or specialization
is that naive bayes models um work out
probabilities of words independent of
their neighbors so what in one part that
a naive bayes language model is a
unigram language model so you're just
using the counts of individual words
but the other part of the naive bayes
model is you're learning a different set
of unigram counts for every class for
your classifier um
and so um
you've then got sort of so effectively a
naive bayes model is you've got
class specific unigram language models
okay
i gave this as a simple statistical
model for estimating your probabilities
with an engram model you can't actually
get away with just doing that because
you have sparsity problems
so you know often will be the case that
for many words students open their books
or students opened their
backpacks just never occurred in the
training data that if you think about it
if you have something like um ten to the
fifth different words even and you want
to have then a sequence of four words a
problem and they're 10 to the fifth of
each there's sort of
10 to the 20th different combinations so
unless you're seeing and it's truly
astronomical amount of data most forward
sequences you've never seen so then
your numerator will be zero and your
probability estimate will be zero and so
that's bad and so the commonest way of
solving that is just to add a little
delta to every count and then everything
is non-zero and that's called smoothing
but well sometimes it's worse than that
because sometimes you won't even have
seen students open theirs and that's
more problematic because that means our
denominator here is zero and so the
division will be ill-defined and we
can't usefully calculate any
probabilities in a context that we've
never seen and so the standard solution
to that is to shorten the context and
that's called back off so we condition
only on open there or if we still don't
haven't seen it open there we'll
condition only on there or we could just
forget all conditioning and actually use
a unigram model for our probabilities
yeah
um
and so
as you increase the
the order n of the engram language model
these sparsity problems
become worse and worse so in the early
days people normally worked with trigram
models as it became easier to collect
billions of words of text
people commonly moved to five gram
models but
every time you go up an order of
conditioning you
effectively need to be collecting orders
of magnitude more data because of the
size of the vocabularies of human
languages
um there's also a problem that these
models are huge um so you basically have
to be caught storing counts of all of
these word sequences so you can work out
these probabilities and i mean that's
actually had a big effect in what terms
of what technology is available um so in
the
2000s decade up till that whenever it
was 2014
that there was already google translate
using
probabilistic models included
language models of the engram language
model sort but the only way they could
possibly be run is in the cloud
because
you needed to have these huge tables of
probabilities
but now we have neural nets and you can
have google translate just actually run
on your phone and that's
possible because
neural net models can be massively more
compact than these old engram language
models
yeah
but nevertheless before we get on to the
newer models
let's just um
sort of look at the example of how these
work so it's trivial to train an engram
language model because you really just
count how often word sequences occur in
a corpus and you're ready to go so these
models can be trained in seconds that's
really good it's not like sitting around
for training neural networks so if i
train on my laptop a small language
model on you know about
1.7 million words as a trigram model i
can then ask it to generate text if i
give it a couple of words today though i
can then
get it to sort of
suggest a word that might come next and
the way i do that is the language model
knows the probability distribution of
things that can come next um note
there's a kind of a crude probability
distribution i mean because effectively
over this relatively small corpus there
were things that occurred once italian
and emirate there are things that
occurred twice price there were things
that occurred um four times company and
bank um it's sort of fairly crude and
rough but i nevertheless get probability
estimates i can
then say okay based on this let's take
this probability distribution and then
we'll just sample the next word so the
two most likely was the sample a company
or bank but we're um rolling the dice
and we might get any of the words that
have come next so maybe i sample price
now i'll condition on price on the price
and look up
the probability distribution of what
comes next the most likely thing is of
and so again i'll sample and maybe this
time i'll pick up of
and then i will now condition on price
of and i will look up the probability
distribution of words following that and
i get this probability distribution
and i'll sample randomly some word from
it and maybe this time i'll sample a
rare but possible one like gold and i
can keep on going and i'll get out
something like this
today the price of gold per ton while
production of shoe lasts and shoe
industry the bank intervened just after
it considered and rejected an imf demand
to rebuild depleted european stocks step
30 n primary 76 cents a share um so what
just a simple trigram model can produce
over not very much text is actually
already kind of interesting like it's
actually surprisingly grammatical right
there are whole pieces of it while
production of shoe last sense you
industry the bank interview intervene
just after it can sit and reject an imf
demand right it's really actually pretty
good grammatical um text so it's um it's
sort of amazing that these simple engram
models actually can model a lot of human
language
on the other hand it's not a very good
piece of text it's completely incoherent
and makes no sense
and so to actually be able to generate
text that seems like it makes sense
we're going to need a considerably
better language model and that's
precisely
what neural language models have allowed
us to build as we'll see later
okay so how can we build a neural
language model and so first of all we're
going to do a simple one
and then
we'll see where we get but to move into
a current neural nets might still take
us the next time
so
going to have input sequence of words
and we want a probability distribution
over the next word um well the simplest
thing that we could try is to say well
kind of the only tool we have so far is
a window-based classifier so what we can
say you know what we've done previously
either for our named entity recognized
in lecture three or what i just showed
you for the dependency parser is we have
some context window we put it through a
neural net and we predict something as a
classifier so before we were predicting
a location but maybe
instead we could reuse exactly the same
technology
and say we're going to have a
window-based classifier so we're
discarding the further away words just
like in
engram language model but we'll feed
this fixed window into a neural net
so we concatenate the word embeddings we
put it through a hidden layer
and then we have a softmax classifier
over
our vocabulary
and so now rather than predicting
something like location or
left arc in the dependency parser we're
going to have a soft max over the entire
vocabulary sort of like we did
with the skipgram negative sampling
model in the first two lectures and so
we're going to see this choice as
predicting what word that comes next
whether it produces laptops minds books
etc
okay so this is a
a fairly simple fixed window neural net
classifier
but this is essentially
a famous early model
in the use of neural nets for nlp
applications um so first a 2000
conference paper and then a somewhat
later
journal paper joshua bengio and
colleagues introduced precisely this
model as the neural probabilistic
language model and they were already
able to show
that this could give interesting good
results for language modeling and so it
wasn't a great solution for neural
language modeling but it still had value
so it didn't solve the problem of
allowing us to have bigger contexts to
predict what words are going to come
next it's in that way limited
exactly like an engram language model is
but it does have all the advantages of
distributed representations
so rather than having
these counts for word sequences that are
very sparse and very crude we can use
distribute distributed representations
of words which then make predictions
that semantically similar words should
give
similar probability distributions so the
idea of that is if we use some other
word here like maybe the pupils open
there um well maybe in our training data
we'd seen sentences about students but
we'd never seen sentences about pupils
an engram language model then would sort
of have no idea what probabilities to
use whereas
a new language model can say well pupils
is kind of similar to students therefore
i can predict similarly to what i would
have predicted for students
okay
so there's now no sparsity problem we
don't need to
store
billions of engram counts we simply need
to store
our word vectors and our w and u
matrices
but we still have the remaining problems
that our fixed window is too small
we can try and make the window larger if
we do that w the w matrix gets bigger
but that also points out another problem
with this model
not only can the window never be large
enough
but
w is just a trained matrix and so
therefore we're learning completely
different weights for each position of
context the word minus one position the
word minus two the word minus three and
the word minus four so that there's no
sharing in the model as to
how it um treats words in different
positions even though in some sense
they will contribute semantic components
that are at least somewhat um
position independent so again for those
of if you sort of think back to either a
naive bayes model or what we saw
with the word to vect model at the
beginning the word to vect model or
naive bayes model completely ignores
word order so it has one set of
parameters regardless of what position
things occur in that doesn't work well
for language modeling because word order
is really important in language modeling
if the last word is the that's a really
good predictor of there being an
adjective or noun following where if the
word for back is the um it doesn't give
you the same information so you do want
to
somewhat
make use of word order but this model is
at the opposite extreme that each
position is being modeled completely
independently
so what we'd like to have is a neural
architecture that can process
an arbitrary amount of context
and have more sharing of the parameters
while still be sensitive to proximity
and so that's the idea of recurrent
neural networks and i'll say about five
minutes about
these today and then next time we'll
return and do more about your of
recurrent neural networks so
for the recurrent neural network rather
than having a single hidden layer inside
our classifier here that we compute each
time
for the recurrent neural network we have
the hidden layer which often is referred
to as the hidden state
but we maintain it over time and we feed
it back into itself um so that's what
the word recurrent is meaning that
you're sort of feeding the hidden layer
back into itself
so what we do
is based on the first word
we compute a hidden representation kind
of like before which can be used to
predict the next word
but then
for when
we want to predict what comes after the
second word we not only feed in the
second word we feed in the hidden
layer from the previous word
to have it help predict the hidden layer
above the second word and so formally
the way we're doing that is we're taking
the hidden layer above the first word
multiplying it by a matrix w
and then that's going to be going in
together with x2 to generate the next
hidden step
and so we keep on doing that at each
time step so that we're kind of
repeating a pattern of creating a next
hidden layer
based on the next input word and the
previous hidden state by updating it by
multiplying it by a matrix w okay so in
my slide here i've still only got four
words of context because it's nice for
my slide but you know
in principle there could be you know any
number of words of context now okay so
what we're doing is so
um
that we start off by having input
vectors which can be
our word vectors that we've looked up
for each word
um
so
sorry yeah so we can have the one hot
vectors for word identity
we look up our word embedding so then
we've got word embeddings for each word
and then we want to compute hidden
states so we need to start from
somewhere h0 is the initial hidden state
and h0 is normally taken as a zero
vector so this is actually just
initialize the zeros and so for working
out the first hidden state we calculate
it based on the first word it's
embedding by multiplying this embedding
by a matrix we and that gives us the
first hidden state
but then
you know as we go on we want to apply
the same formula over again so we have
just two
parameter matrices
in the recurrent neural network
one matrix for multiplying input
embeddings and one matrix for updating
the hidden state of the network and so
for the second word
from its word embedding we multiply
it by
the we matrix we take the previous time
steps hidden state and multiply it by
the wh
matrix and we use the two of those um to
generate the new hidden state and
precisely how we generate the new hidden
state is then by shown on this equation
on the left
so we take the previous hidden state
multiply it by wh we take the
input embedding multiply it by w e
we sum those two
we add
on a learn bias weight and then we put
that through a non-linearity
and although on this slide that
non-linearity is written as sigma by far
the most common non-linearity to use
here actually is a tan h non linearity
and so this is the core equation
for a simple recurrent neural network
and for each successive time step we're
just going to keep on applying that to
work out hidden states
and then from those hidden states we can
use them just like in our window
classifier to predict what would be the
next word so at any position we can take
this hidden vector
put it through a soft max layer which is
multiplying by u matrix and adding on
another bias and then making a soft max
distribution out of that and that will
then give us the probability
distribution over next words
what we saw here right this is
the entire math of a simple recurrent
neural network and next time i'll come
back and
say more about them but this is the
entirety of
of what you need to know in some sense
for the computation of the forward model
of a simple recurrent neural network so
the advantages we have now as it can
process at a text input of any length
in theory at least it can use
information from any number of steps
back we'll talk more about in practice
how well it actually works
the model size is fixed it doesn't
matter how much
of a past context there is all we have
is our wh and we parameters
and at each time step
we use exactly the same weights to
update our hidden state um so there's a
symmetry in how different inputs are
processed in producing our predictions
um rnns in practice though or these
simple rnns and practice aren't perfect
so um a disadvantage is that they're
actually kind of slow because with this
recurrent computation
in some sense we are sort of stuck with
having to have on the outside of for
loop so we can do vector matrix
multiplies on the inside here but really
we have to do for time step equals 1 to
n
calculate the successive hidden states
and so that's not a perfect neural net
architecture and we'll
discuss alternatives to that later
and although in theory this model can
access information any number of steps
back in practice we find
that it's pretty imperfect at doing that
and that will then lead to
more advanced forms of recurrent neural
network that i'll talk about next time
that are able to more effectively access
past context
okay i think i'll stop there for the day